Bonjour Éric Zemmour. Vous avez regardé le
documentaire du réalisateur Pierre Barnérias
Hold-up, consacré à la crise de la Covid-19 et vous
ironisez sur ce mot de complotisme, cette accusation
souvent faite à l'égard de ce reportage. Oui parce
que je pense que ce documentaire ne mérite ni
cet excès d'honneur ni cet excès d'indignité selon la fameuse formule.
C'est à dire que je le prends, je l'ai regardé, j'ai
trouvé ça interminable, beaucoup trop long mais
avec beaucoup de choses très intéressantes. Et
la thèse en revanche finaliste que je ne
partage pas qui est en gros pour résumer : ce virus
fabriqué à l'institut Pasteur, envoyé ensuite
aux chinois aurait été le prétexte pour permettre
aux partisans du gouvernement mondial, Bill Gates,
Attali, etc, d'imposer aux populations une
crypto-monnaie qui permettrait vous savez de
puisque vous payez avec votre téléphone ou
avec d'autres choses, de vous contrôler et de
contrôler tout ce que vous faites, tout que vous
achetez. J'avoue que la thèse ne me convaincpas.
En revanche, dans les deux heures et demie
que dure ce reportage, il y a beaucoup de choses
très intéressantes et beaucoup de choses très
pertinentes et des choses que je savais et
d'autres que j'ignorais. Donc je trouve
un peu rapide et un peu facile et très douteux de
voir toute la caste médiatique, politique lui
tomber dessus en disant "complotistes". Et pour
avoir moi même subi ce genre d'agressions avec ce
mot là, je sais maintenant que quand toute la caste
politico-médiatique vous traite de complotiste, ça
veut dire que vous essayez, alors en vous trompant
parfois, en réussissant d'autrefois, à voir ce qu'il y a
derrière le rideau. Donc le complotisme
c'est devenu l'arme de guerre des élites pour
défendre leur vérité leur pré carré contre des
gens qui essayent d'en savoir plus. Même si je
vous dis, en l'occurrence, derrière des choses
très justes sur Raoult, sur toute la
gestion de cette pandémie complètement folle,
en particulier celle du gouvernement français. La
thèse ne me convainc pas, la thèse finale. Mais je
sais ce que c'est que le mot complotisme.
Oui mais enfin quand même, défendre la liberté
d'expression, pourfendre ceux qui dénoncent le
complotisme ne permet pas dire n'importe quoi.
Non bien sûr. Je vous dis, j'essaye
de comprendre pourquoi on le traite de complotiste.
Et je comprends. C'est à dire que, il n'y a plus
de débat intellectuel possible si on interdit à
l'autre d'avoir une part d'analyses.
En plus c'est très intéressant,
parce que qu'est ce que nous disent tous
ceux qui tombent sur ce pauvre metteur en scène ?
En plus apparemment il est plutôt tendance mystique,
il a fait des reportages sur la vierge.
C'est carrément un crime contre l'humanité, donc
on en rajoute évidemment. Donc qu'est ce qu'on
nous dit ?  On nous dit : il y a une vérité et il ne
faut pas la contester. Et pourtant ce sont nos
élites depuis 40 ans, depuis les campus américains
des années 40, tout les progressistes qui nous ont
appris qu'il n'y avait pas de vérité avec un grand
un grand V, qui nous ont expliqué à longueur de journée à
longueur de livres que la vérité était relative,
qu'elle était le produit de nos conditionnements
sociaux, raciaux, sexuels genrés comme on dit
aujourd'hui et que même la langue n'était pas
neutre et que c'était une arme
de combat et qu'il fallait la retourner, qu'il
fallait changer les mots, la grammaire etc.
Que la vérité n'existe pas
et qu'elle est floue, qu'elle est liquide comme
on dit aujourd'hui comme la société liquide.
Et donc évidemment nous avons été bien éduqué donc
aujourd'hui nous retournons cet argument contre
ces élites qui trouvent ça scandaleux.
Selon-vous vous ceux qui dénoncent le complotisme ont tout
fait pour qu'on y croit. C'est exactement ça et
ont tout fait pour, justement pour qu'on ne
croit pas à la vérité officielle, même si parfois
elle peut être juste. Mais ils nous ont appris à
douter de tout en fonction justement, même de la
plus évidente: l'Histoire de France, la patrie, la
famille, tout ce qui était ancré profondément en nous.
Et on nous a appris à douter de tout et maintenant
ces mêmes élites qui ont sapé les fondements de
la société traditionnelle avec ce doute
principiel, nous disent : ah bah non il faut pas douter de
ce qu'on dit. C 'est pas possible ça.